RIM RIM BALL WITH KELLY HRUDEY
IN BOQUIST NEAR THE
LINE.
DOWN LOW.
SHARANGO RITCHIE.
HE SCORES!
HIS FIRST GOAL, FIRST POINT OF
THE SEASON AND THE FLAMES POSITN
GRAVES.
AND THE FLAMES GO MERCER.
SCORES!
MERCER GOES TOP CORNER.
MIGHT HAVE RELEASE.
NOTICE HOW HEBLOCKED IN FRONT.
STILL LOOSE.
THEY SCORE!
MANGIAPANE PUTS IT HOME!
AND GETS HIS WAY AND CHANGE DIR.
CERTAINLY GETS A STICK HIGH.
RITCHI SHOTS
THROUGH.
IT WENT RIGHT THROUGH TO THE
BACK OF THE GOAL AS SUBBAN
SNEAKS HISCHIER OR
>> DILLON DUBE TURUR GETTING SOE
RECENTLY.
AND YOU GOT TO A NICE SHOT.
I DON'T THINK THAT HITS THE
STICK OF
AND THE FLAMES TAKE A 5-2 LEAD.K
HERE.
YES, SIR.
>> Louie: OH, YEAH, FOR SURE.
GREAT EYES, RICK.OLI.
MONAEY SCORE?
SHARANGOVICH ON A QUICK SETUP,
ABLE TO FIRE IT HOME AND CUT THG
PLAYER AND HE HAS A REAL BRATT.
HUGHES FEEDS IT THROUGH.
ANOTHER CHANCE.
GREAT SAVET REALLY
TIMELY SAVE BY
TKACHUK.
STOPPED BY GILLIES!
TERRIFIC SAVE OF HOME GAMES.
8 OF 9 COMING QUICK
HE'LL BREAK IT DOWN THE MIDDLE.
COLEMAN BACKHAND, STOPPED B.
KEPT IN BY LINDHOLM.
HERE'S GAUDREAU.
IN FRONT!
[ HornIS IS HOW DO YOU IT.
RASMUS ANDERSSON TO